[Music]
[Music]
and hamed abdellalim wants to know this
what role does the higgs boson play in
quantum physics actually you could have
asked that question about any particle
the the proton the neutron the the
electron neutrinos
quarks they are all subject the laws of
the quantum
actually so is the whole universe but
the smaller you are the more you
manifest these laws
and so the higgs boson
it's a quantum particle
and how does the higgs boson work it
makes a field
and that field grants mass to any
particle that moves through it
it's a badass particle if you have to be
a particle that would be the one to be
don't tell anybody but that's the one to
be
and you might ask how does it actually
assign mass
think of a hollywood party
if you
go to a hollywood party and nobody knows
you you can just go straight to the bar
like that
you have low hollywood mass
if you are famous and you walk into the
party everyone gathers around you they
want your autograph they want to take
your picture and you're working towards
the bar but you're moving really slow
you have a lot of inertia slow inertia
and you can't get through the man you
can't get through it so you have high
hearty mass
the hollywood party is exactly the higgs
field so what party is it where
you sit home and lament your career and
cry
what particle is that that's the neutron
it has no charge so therefore
it can attract no one
[Music]
tim gur says do two entangled particles
communicate faster than the speed of
light i've heard it's apparently instant
it turns out
one of the rules of quantum physics is
that because particles are also waves
if there's a particle on this side of a
hill and it can't get across to the
other side
the wave function
does exist and actually exist in a
little bit on the other side of the hill
so the electron can disappear here and
reappear there collapsing the wave
function and the electron would have
moved from there to there instantly
basically faster than the speed of light
it's called
quantum mechanical tunneling and it
happens all the time
and it is mysterious and beautiful
so what's the hype about tachyons then
so tachyon is a hypothetical particle
named for being very fast tachyosa's
greek for speed the tachometer gets the
it's the same route so a tachyon is a
particle hypothetical particle that
exists only faster than light
and it can go to infinitely high speeds
and the slowest you can ever get this
thing to go is the speed of light itself
it turns out this is not violated in
einstein's equations
because
you're not crossing the speed of light
you're coming into existence faster than
the speed of light and you put that into
the equations it ends up living
backwards in time
this is a backwards time traveling
particle hypothesized we've never
discovered one
so we don't know if they really exist
they probably don't but it's fun to talk
about them because they don't violate
einstein's relativity equation
[Music]
schrodinger's cat relates a little bit
to what people have called the observer
effect
okay where if you observe something you
change it so i can respond to both of
those in the same
in the same pop if you allow me okay so
let's do the observer effect for the
moment so it's unfortunate that somebody
called it the observer effect because
then new age folk and other people who
were basically scientifically illiterate
were thinking it's your consciousness
that affects what you're observing and
oh my gosh there's a consciousness field
and they go running off in a you know
off the cliff see what you don't
understand is that like particles
are totally alive
okay
and the reason why there is a collective
consciousness in the universe is because
like all of these particles that are
spinning what they're actually doing is
conducting thought and consciousness
they're thinking they're thinking
they're thinking man
rocks think trees think yeah
more than rocks right so let me let me
cut through all of that and simply say
that you're sitting there and i can see
you
because in fact you're illuminated by if
not sunlight through an open window
an uncurtained window but artificial
light within the room all right that
light hits your face bounces off your
face goes through the computing system
and i see you okay
that light carries energy
every photon of light that strikes your
face carries energy
and then they they most of them reflect
others uh get absorbed actually depends
on how dark your skin is it's getting
very dark it'll absorb most of them if
you have that because you know photons
they want to be a part of this baby
let me give something
let me give you guys
i see where we're landing
oh we got some good chocolate and
there's over here
so
here's the thing if i made you tinier
and tinier and tinier right so you're no
longer a macroscopic human you're a
microscopic particle
there's a particle size below which
when you open the curtains and shine
light on you
that light will hit you and pop you into
another location so i'm smaller than the
photon then what the your whatever your
your capacity to move to a different
state of existence that the energy that
that is required to make that happen
correct
energy the same as the energy of the
light that's hitting you gotcha so you
hit me
with in order
in order to see you
right and then you pop somewhere else
and i say where'd you go right what are
you doing so am i there am i not there
well we'll never really know
because you're hitting me with something
that makes me not there once you're
exposing me to it correct and and since
it happens on the moment you're exposed
not the moment i see you right i will
never know what you were doing exactly
okay if you're small enough for that
light energy to to affect you in that
way so that's why we don't think about
this in everyday life because we're too
big for light to pop us into other
states of existence exactly but
particles electrons atoms
all of this it happens all the time and
this was a very disturbing discovery in
the 1920s we're in the centennial decade
of the discovery of quantum physics in
the 1920s because you discover this i
want to see what you're doing oh my gosh
you're not going to let me see what
you're doing
because the light i shine on you in
order to see it is so it's really uh
it's not so much an observer effect it's
a measurement effect exactly okay get
the human brain out it's just a device
to measure you you you can't know it
okay right
[Music]
so
here's what happens you say to yourself
um you put a cat in a box
and if the cat is a quantum cat
with two states
states of existence it's either dead or
alive
while it's in the box you have no idea
which it is
and so the way we describe this in
quantum physics if you do the
experiments
okay
so some percentage of the time you open
the box the cat will be alive others the
cat will be dead and so you
what we say is that the the cat's
existence
is a superposition of being dead and
being alive
[Music]
so the wishing bone experiment it's the
wishing bone experiment okay so we break
the wish the wishbone in half we don't
look at our pieces one has a big piece
one is a small piece i go to andromeda i
look at mine and i find out i have the
big piece i instantly know you have the
small piece now there's nothing
surprising about that because it was
established at the table
which one had the big piece which one
had the small piece right now quantum
entanglement
is much weirder it says we break the
wishing bone and it's at simultaneously
in a state where i have the small piece
you have the big piece and
i have the big piece you have the small
piece it has not yet been determined
by any entity
no it is completely in a what we call a
superposition
but it has to match we can't both have
the small piece and we can't both have
the big
piece why the two states are not we both
have the big piece it's i big you little
you become little right
exactly but they have to match because
they have to fit together to make the
original wishing bone
right but it's not actually determined
who has the big piece yet
and quantum mechanics allows me for this
you can't know
is there some higher dimension is there
god
who would know
well if you're real adherent to quantum
mechanics you would say that you've
disproven the possibility of omniscience
being
because no it is it is not established
in some sense when we in our
conventional thinking
are accustomed to see thinking certain
things are real
what's real is the piece of the chicken
bone is real we're sure of it but it's
not in some sense
real
what's real is the probability
that's real and that's determined and
that is absolutely deterministic and can
be predicted the probability
but the the existence of the pieces of
bone themselves are not yet
actualized they don't actually have a
concrete existence so you're saying
um you and i are entangled with each
other right right right and we have to
be obtained
right we have to be entangled because we
can't both have the small piece because
that's not cool so we have to be
entangled in such a way that we make we
fit together correctly to make the
original wishing bone so i can have the
small piece you could have the big piece
i could have the big piece you could
have a small piece
but we don't know which one it is yet
it's not just that we don't know it's
that it doesn't actually assume
a precise state yet
okay so when when does it assume that
precise state because at some point this
can't just be potential
at some point there has to be a
realization
of who has what peace
so yeah when does that happen and how do
we determine that and how do we observe
that so superpositions are very delicate
so when they do it as you were saying uh
neil like in the laboratory everyone's
trying to do this in the lab and it's
it's very very very delicate you have to
have systems that are not disrupted or
disturbed
in any way so there was this sort of
mystique that once i i went to andromeda
and i looked at it that the act of my
conscious looking
forced it to assume a certain state and
that's not really quite right what
happened was just all the molecules in
my body and the air that i'm breathing
and the room all of these things uh
destroy the delicate superposition they
they knock it about it imagine you know
a pencil standing on its end so yeah if
you go and clumsily look at it you knock
it over but it doesn't have to do with
your consciousness
it's just the interaction of all the
particles and all the molecules and all
those things that make it impossible for
it to maintain this delicate state of
standing on its point
okay so now so now the state becomes
actualized in front of you
yes so now i look and i know for sure
i've got the big piece i won
but what happened is
i somehow seemingly forced
faster than the speed of light from
andromeda to the earth instantaneously
forced your your state to also assume a
precise state
because you can't know that without me
also knowing my state right
well
i can look at it and know it and i
instantaneously know
you have the smaller
piece of bone and that's that but you
don't necessarily whether i've looked
yet or not that's right so but that's
but that's only because
the
the
the two there has to be that balance of
big and small that's the only reason
it's right they have they have to fit
together to make the original wishing
bone exactly it can't be that i look at
mine and then you also look at yours and
we both have a big piece of wishing bone
[Music]
eric theoretically dr tyson do you think
a superhero with the power of
inter-universal travel
could ever be truly possible or with the
probability of the laws of physics in
other universes
being different from ours prevent that
from ever happening could somebody do it
awesome question so in the multiverse
concept yes uh
these by the way in thor
that is what happens it is the
inter-universal travel because thor
opens
from his world opens up a portal no no
no his world i think his world is in our
universe he just the portal gets you
from his world
all right so there you go isn't isn't
that world sectors and we're one of
those sectors i think it is i think
you're right you're right there's six
sectors right and we're one of them
we're one of them and so this is easy
access from one sector so that's a
wormhole that's a wormhole it's
essentially a wormhole but this would be
an inter-universal portal from the
moment i got you so in the multiverse
it's it's prescribed by the fact that
these are fluctuations in the quantum
the early quantum universe all right and
quantum physics uh is a fascinating
understanding of the structure of matter
on the smallest scales right
there's there's particles that pop in
and out of existence i mean it's a
stunning reality that exists at those
scales now the whole universe doesn't do
that
unless the entire universe were the size
of an atom
then when you pop particles in and out
of existence you're actually popping
universes in and out of existence
[Music]
what i'm asking you as a theoretical
physicist leading theoretical physicist
we have an observation an astronomical
observation and it forces you to go back
and re-tweak
are you tweaking big bang you tweaking
quantum physics
you're tweaking what are you tweaking
well in this particular case you really
are tweaking
something that we yet don't understand
fully which is dark matter so that's
right for being tweaked but look there
dark matter is like mysterious gravity
of the universe we have no idea what's
causing it but but i'll give you another
example which has happened recently
right there have been measurements of
the rate of the expansion of space
and those measurements very recently are
seeming to be incompatible with earlier
measurements done in a different way
because he had a whole other uh recent
result a whole other research exactly
and this one if it's correct this is one
that could really change our
understanding of the early universe
dramatically right in order to get the
measurements that are done on the
expansion of space looking at the
microwave background radiation and those
that are coming from looking at
supernova explosions to get those
compatible right now is going to require
perhaps tweaking the dark energy it may
require tweaking our understanding of
the gravitational force i mean there are
many things that may come into that
particular reconciliation our
understanding of the gravitational force
itself yeah i mean whenever you talk
about dark energy right everyone knows
what dark energy is yeah well i'm just
saying some people at home may not
right so this energy filling space that
we believe yields a repulsive gravity
that's causing the universe to speed up
in its acceleration and when it
theoretically should be
slowing down it's all right sorry
ordinary gravity pulls things together
it should be slowing down okay the shock
that we got in 1998 is that it's not
slowing down the rate of expansion
speeding up against the wishes of
gravity
and well here's the thing we didn't
understand gravity well enough gravity
can not only be attractive it can be
repulsive and that really wasn't taken
into account until about 1998 when it
comes to cosmology now the possibility
is maybe this outward push is itself
getting stronger over time and so that
means thinking it was one thing would be
an incomplete understanding of that
phenomenon yes and which would actually
change everything but that's just which
is why you have to tweak
string theory
yeah
[Music]